you
[Music]
okay welcome back hopefully everyone
enjoyed a nice lunch got a little Sun
we're okay so we have a series of talks
this afternoon we have an array of
topics as we did this morning we're
going to start with Ronald the wolf and
he's going to speak with us about
quantum stp solvers thanks is anybody
have a clicker that I could borrow from
Ecch
this one's about g6 thanks
Oh
this is good
okay
good so I hope the microphone is working
well happy to be here thanks Krista for
inviting me so this is going to be a
talk about quantum algorithms more
specifically quantum algorithms for
solving semi-definite programs and we're
really following the footsteps of Krista
and Fernando brandão here who first came
up with such an algorithm last year and
we improved this a number of ways so
this is joint work with my students
Euron's on Apeldoorn under Celia and who
is here and so on the grape Ling let me
start a little bit by just telling you
what linear programs and semi-definite
programs are so most people have seen
this before but let me tell you what
what a linear program is so linear
program just optimizes some linear
function of n real variables so X here
is a vector of n real variables and we
want to optimize some some weighted
function of those variables so sum over
I Cixi subject to a bunch of linear
constraints on this vector X and subject
to a non negativity constraint right so
linear programs they can have all sorts
of forms but you can always massage him
to be this standard form
and these things are very important tool
in optimization ever since the 1940s
when Don C developed the simplex
algorithm to solve such problems I think
he was helping the US Army with its
logistics operations so let's think this
this method for helping win the Second
World War and not on so the simplex
algorithm it works very fast in practice
most of the time it's worst case
exponential time which is not great but
there exists other algorithms that have
worst case polynomial time
so in particular kutcheon was the first
to show that you could solve linear
programs efficiently even in the worst
case and this result was so important
that it even made it to the new york
times which is something that not many
scientists reach and a more general
framework for optimization there
so-called semi definite programs and
here the set up is exactly the same
you're optimizing some linear function
subject to linear constraints that the
variable now is not an n-dimensional
vector with an N by n matrix so you
still have a linear function of the
matrix entry so this this Tracy
product here you can think of it as a
sum over all the IJ entries of the
matrix of some weight CIJ think of it as
a cost for instance times the matrix
entry X IJ so it's still a linear
function of the N squared variables and
there's now linear matrix constraints on
your variable capital X right so the
trace of some fixed matrix AJ with your
variable X should be less than some
specified BJ and the no like identity
constraints of the vector here is being
replaced by a positive semi-definite
this constraint on the variable X so in
particular if all these matrices here
were diagonal you just have the linear
programming case but of course semi
definite programs have more expressive
power and this sometimes makes a big
difference so this is still solvable in
polynomial time and in some cases a
famous example is approximation
algorithms for finding the maximal cut
in a graph you can find a relaxation of
that that np-hard problem finding the
maximal cuts you can find a relaxation
as an SDP that gives you much better
approximation factor in polynomial time
than any linear program could alright so
these are important optimization
problems and they're solvable in
polynomial time but of course we want
them to be as fast as possible so as low
degree of polynomial as possible
and that's that's essentially what this
talk is about so whenever you have a
semi definite program like this one here
this is just copied from the previous
slide there's an equivalent dual
semi-different program it's called so
that's the one I wrote here and if you
look at primal dual SDPs or even LPS the
variables and the constraints they sort
of switch place so here we would have an
n-dimensional variable namely the matrix
X and we would have M constraints so J
arranges here of the numbers 1 up to M
and those two numbers switch roles in
the dual program so here our variable is
an M dimensional vector Y and we want to
minimize some weighted combination of
those wise subjects to one very big PSD
constraint so this is saying that the
left-hand side which is a big matrix
minus the right-hand side should be PSD
and the constraint here is that the
vector of variables Y is greater or
equal to 0 and under mild conditions
which will always be satisfied
here the optimal these two programs are
actually the same that's called strong
duality right so you could choose to
solve either one you can even try to
solve both of them right so just to
repeat if you look at the primal then n
is the dimension of the primal so X is
an N by n matrix and M is the number of
its constraint those are two important
parameters which will govern the
complexity of sort of algorithms to
solve this and for normalization
purposes we're going to assume that
these matrices C and AJ which are really
the inputs to your SDP that those are
normalizing operator norm we're also
going to assume that there are somewhat
sparse so s is going to denote the
sparsity of these matrices the sparse
are they are the better in terms of the
speed of solving this
so the sparsity mean so these matrices
are as FAR's means that every row and
every column in these matrices has at
most s nonzero entries we're also going
to assume some upper bound on the trace
of feasible solutions here and we're
even going to add that to the primal SDP
so I'm just going to add a constraint
here you can think of this as the zero
constraint this of course also affects
the dual right if you if you add an
extra constraints to the primal it then
your dual changes and it changes like
this so there's now an extra term here
on the right-hand side of the PSD
constraint one extra dual variable y 0
as well and also the objective function
of the dual has an extra term now this
is obvious technicalities we're also
going to assume an upper bound on the l1
norm of dual solutions but we won't add
that as a constraint this is for
technical reasons and the goal here is
going to be to quickly approximate the
optimal value right so the optimal value
of the primal and of the dual are the
same I'm going to denote that with opt
the optimal value it's typically very
hard to compute that exactly it might
even be impossible to compute it exactly
because this this could be a supremum
rather than a maximum so our goal is
going to be to approximate this with
within some additive error epsilon right
the smaller epsilon the more time this
will cost of course
so this is our goal and let's first talk
about what's known for classical
algorithm solving SDP this is a big
industry like there's a lot of work on
fast linear program solvers there's also
a lots may be a little bit less but
still a lot of work on on efficient SDP
solvers because these things are used
all over the place and the best
algorithm that I'm aware of that has
very good dependence on the epsilon is a
very recent thing disappeared in Fox
2015 and there's a dependence on the
number of constraints M and a dimension
n looks like this all right so this is
polynomial time that the degrees are not
so small so for instance it depends like
a third power on the number of
constraints it depends like so this is
the so-called
matrix exponentiation exponent it also
depends polynomial eon and so this is a
polynomial time algorithm but it's not
that great because the polynomial has a
relatively large degree so Aurora and
Cali they had a different approach to
solving SDPs which gives you a trade-off
in the sense that the dependence on the
parameters N and M is better that the
dependence on certain other parameters
in particular this epsilon error here
that's a lot worse right in particularly
they achieve a linear dependence on the
product MN and a polynomial dependence
on epsilon so here epsilon comes in poly
logarithmically so you can fairly
efficiently make the epsilon very small
the dependence on epsilon in the other
akale solver is much worse but the
dependence on mm is much better right
some you win some you lose so here's the
idea in fact this is the idea of many of
these solvers it's to do a binary search
for the optimal value right remember
this is the quantity we're trying to
approximate what we want to find out and
the idea is that you start with some
guess for what the optimal value should
be I guess initially your your guess
could be kind of off but you're supposed
to correct this guess by increasing or
decreasing it so let's say we start with
a guess alpha for this optimal value
then one thing you could do is you could
add the constraint saying that the dual
objective function is at most alpha you
can add that to your dual problem now if
the actual optimal value is at most
alpha then your dual problem will remain
feasible right because you basically
haven't you haven't changed the opposite
if the actual optimum is is less than is
at most alpha then putting this
constraint here doesn't change anything
because the dual problem is a
minimization problem right the minimum
would actually like the low alpha so
this constraint doesn't change the
optimal value so you add that constraint
to your Google and then you check if the
resulting dual is still a feasible
problem if yes then we know that our
guess was was too high and we can
decrease it accordingly if on the other
hand this problem is no longer feasible
then our guest alpha was too low we sort
of made the problem infeasible by
putting this extra constraint and then
we know that we have to increase our
guess right then you can sort of move
this guess alpha up and down until it
converges sort of within a range of
Epsilon around the actual optimal value
right so this reduces the whole problem
to just testing feasibility of over dual
LP SDP and so to test that with a given
guess alpha we're going to alter
alternates well not we but Arora and
callek we're going to alternate between
primal and dual guesses for the primal
and dual SDP converting to a dual
feasible solution if one exists and this
is how we're going to decide whether or
not this sort of Augmented version of
the dual is still feasible or not still
has a feasible solution and sort of the
core inside this this primal dual step
is an Oracle and the idea of the Oracle
is that you feed it a primal solution
and it spits out some information about
how you should update the primal
solution so I'll explain that like that
next because this is sort of the
technical core of the erotically method
so here's what you have here this is
just the feasible region of the dual SDP
if you were to add this extra constraint
saying that the the optimal value in the
dual is at most your guess Epsilon right
our goal is to test whether or not this
is feasible or not and you might look at
this a little bit strangely but this is
actually equivalent to the PhD
constraint we had before right so this
is equivalent to saying that the sum
over J of a DIY J is greater or equal to
C
PUSD constraint so this is just the
Augmented version of the dual of course
I haven't really changed much but now we
can start to relax this dual to make it
much simpler and therefore eat more
easily solvable right so our goal is to
to either find a y in this feasible
region or conclude that non exists and
if we're given a particular primal
solution row so so let's say some PSD
matrix of trace 1 if this is our current
primal solution then we can relax this
is dual SDP in two ways so first of all
this constraint here this is asking some
inequality to hold for every possible
PSD matrix row if we're given a specific
row then we can relax this this this
this this problem by only requiring this
for the particular row that we're
starting with right and this is a
relaxation which means we're growing the
set P right so we could we could require
this constraint here to hold only for
the specific primal solution row that we
have now rather than all rows this is a
relaxation and a second relaxation is we
could allow a little bit of slack here
in this inequality right so we're being
like like the Dutch trucks policies for
being a little bit liberal here we're
allowing more than we really should and
this is the second relaxation so both of
these steps make this poly tell PE ta
make it bigger but notice that if this
bigger region is still empty then
certainly the original dual echo
Clementi dual was was infeasible and we
can still conclude that our guests are
guests alpha was - what is it too big so
we're now going to try to solve in the
next bunch of slides or well not in the
next bunch of slides but somewhere in
the middle of the talk we're going to
try to solve this is simpler the simpler
problem and if you look at it you
realize that this is actually just an LP
this is a linear program with only two
constraints even right this is one
constraint and if you fix the row then
trace AJ Row is just a number and Trey's
C roll is just a number so what you have
here is just one linear constraint in
the variables
why J so we've now relaxed this this
dual SDP to a very simple linear program
that there's only two constraints and
there's one complexity measure four four
four so our Oracle is going to have to
spit out a Y in this set if it exists
and there's an important complexity
measure associated with this that's
called the width of the Oracle and the
width of the Oracle you can think of it
as a norm of a select matrix so to speak
and the complexity of the algorithm is
going to be upper bounded in terms of
this width and you can upper bound deter
the the width by using triangle
inequality and using the fact that the
sum of the Y J's is assumed to be at
most little art so from the little R we
get an upper bound on the width so this
is his Oracle and I'll come back to this
later when we're trying to sort of write
more efficient procedures to spit out
the Y in this set P if it exists which
is what ahora calls supposed to do it
so with this Oracle like I can sketch
the Oracle a framework so the idea is
the following let me just repeat the
inputs so that the inputs are the
matrices a J and C in effect also the
the right-hand sides be J of the primal
SBP some number R capital R which upper
bounds the trace of dual of primal
feasible solutions a width bound W and
our desired approximation error episode
so remember our goal is to optimize to
two to find the optimal value opt within
plus or minus Epsilon and the way we do
it is we have a specific guess alpha and
we want to test whether that's too high
or too low so that we can improve it in
the right direction so the output of
this algorithm is either going to be the
word lower meaning we should reduce our
guest Epsilon because it was too big or
some dual feasible by sorry and sorry in
that case we can also output a dual
feasible Y or it's going to find that
this poly tope was empty so the problem
was infeasible and that means that our
guess alpha was too lower we should
increase it so it's an iterative
algorithm and the number of iterations
is going to be essentially this here so
the width squared times capital R
squared over epsilon squared
you can already see that this is not
great when for instance epsilon is very
small or when capital R is very big
there's also a log factor here which I
omitted we put in this ETA parameter
which was involved in the second
relaxation step for the Oracle we'll set
it to this value here and then we have
an initial primal guess so our initial
primal guess is just going to be the
identity matrix normalized to have trace
1 and then we're going to iterate right
then it's a primal dual method so we're
bouncing back and forth between primal
and dual solutions for capital T
iterations and so we first run the
Oracle this relax this relaxation of the
Augmented dual problem we're going to
run it with our current primal solution
so initially with Row 1
this guy here but in general with row
little P and this is either going to
tell us that the this relaxed molecule
was empty that the Oracle fails to find
a vector Y in that set and at that case
we're already done we know that our
guest alpha is too small and we should
increase it so in that case the
algorithm returns here you should you
should go higher and stops and otherwise
something interesting and slightly
complicated happens so if if the Oracle
dips provide us with an Y that we need
to update our primal solution and the
way to do that is to to define this
matrix MT here which is going to be
essentially the Select matrix with this
particular vector Y normalized to have
at most operator norm one remember this
w here this width of the Oracle this was
an upper bound on how big the operator
norm of this guy could be so if you
divide by W then MP will have operator
norm at most one and we're going to add
this to a matrix H which were sort of
keeping track of and in every step of
the algorithm in every iteration we're
adding a new MT to that H and then we
define a new primal solution like this
so this kind of looks like a quantum
state right in this one that's where
we'll go next
and this is kind of mysterious like
what's actually happening here I think
the way to think about this is this MT
here so you can think of MT as a
direction in which your your primal
solution is kind of wrong
and you can think of this addition here
it's trying to correct your primal
solution in the right direction this is
this is a bit intuitive right so you can
do this Oracle like it's sort of it
produces a row one then a y1 then a row
2 then I buy 2 etc and it can go on for
hours if you want and but after this
many iterations you're just going to
stop and the y you will you will return
will be just the average over the
different wise that were produced by the
Oracle in the capital T different
iterative steps and now something
magical occurs and that is that this
sector Y here this is going to be
extremely close to feasible for the dual
STP not quite feasible you have to mess
a little bit with one coordinate so you
add a little bit with this one
coordinate we're using the sector that
the first constraint matrix is identity
corresponding to the trace valve and
then you can show that this is actually
dual feasible right so what is algorithm
does repeatedly is it sort of bounces
back and forth between primal and dual
and either it figures out that a dual
with this particular guess of alpha is
infeasible that means that our alpha was
too smaller we should increase it or it
actually finds a feasible by and that
means that our guess for alpha was too
high and we can lower it right and this
is sort of we we we hopefully shift this
elf until it converges into some small
range so this is the Aurora Cali
framework it's it's it's an instance of
the matrix multiplicative weights method
and if you look at this here than any
quantum person who is worth his salt
will recognize something here so but on
Darwin's flora they latched on this last
year with the observation that you can
actually interpret this state here as a
quantum state right this is a density
matrix and it's a very special density
matrix it's a so-called gift space right
it's an N by n state so it's you could
think of it as a log n cubed state it's
called the Gib state so this matrix H
you can interpret it as a Hamiltonian
it's it's going to be a hermitian matrix
you can interpret it as a molto nyan and
you can interpret this matrix row as the
gift state corresponding to that
Hamiltonian
and this gives you a way to actually
make the algorithm quantum and faster so
that's what Brundle Owens wanted it
so they observed that the quantum
computer can actually prepare copies of
this matrix row as a log and cubed
quantum states it can do that repeatedly
and you can use that for instance to
approximate these values here by
repeated measurements and these values
here are important because they are
essentially the coefficients in one of
the two constraints of this relaxed LP
remember we have this this augmented
dual STP which if you relax it really
just becomes a linear program and the
important constraints in that linear
program these are the coefficients there
right so by preparing this as a quantum
state and doing repeated measurements
you can approximate those coefficients
very well and then you're ready to run
your Oracle in addition they also got an
improvement
the quantum speed-up for that Oracle
using something called a James principle
that's are actually one of the things we
get rid of in our in our improvement of
the algorithm so I won't explain what
that is and their quantum SDP solver if
you work it out it has this this total
runtime
so this ode tilde is this hype' some
work vectors the important thing here is
the square root dependence on m and n
right this is quadratically better than
what our Oracle a classically could do
so this is a significant improvement you
lose a little bit in the sparsity so
this becomes so the sparsity in
erotically was linear
it becomes quadratic here but kind of
the downside here is the the bad
dependence on these other parameters
capital R which was an upper bound on
the trace in the primal and this this
error parameter epsilon right these are
I mean this is polynomial time but only
in the theoretician sense of polynomial
and this algorithm was for the special
case where the bj coefficients in the
primal or at least one and also where
the guess alpha is at least one that's a
technicality so they have a reduction
that allows them to reduce to this case
right so the bottom line is this
algorithm has it has a wonderful idea
it taking our Oracle a framework you
interpret everything as quantum states
and you get a faster algorithm it's
faster in m and n that it has kind of
that dependence on these other
parameters right so what is our result
our result is essentially just to
improve the dependence on these
parameters
and it's still going to be bats like
like it will be better but still going
to be bad so let me explain what we did
so we we sort of followed in the
footsteps of Krista and Fernando and we
have two main improvements to their
approach so for one thing so if you want
to estimate these quantities here so
think of the a matrix as one of the AJ's
or maybe the C matrix of the primal and
you want to estimate this quantity here
which you need to do in your Oracle
because this is one of the coefficients
in the Oracle constraint so if you want
to estimate this one way to do that is
just to prepare a whole bunch of copies
of Rho and then just measure those you
viewing a as an observable you can
actually do that faster by doing
everything coherently and using using
amplitude amplification and then you get
this complexity here so this this
quantity here trace of a row where Rho
is the gift state corresponding to H you
can estimate it in this this amount of
time this is not just query complexity
by the way all the bounds I'm stating I
really the wrong time of the algorithm
it's not just theory complexity it's
really gate count so that's one
improvement and this is kind of
technical so if you look at this so
we're using a lot of ingredients that
are known in literature right there's a
lot of work already on quantum Gibson
first one is this David has a paper
about this we couldn't really use
off-the-shelf results so we had to redo
a lot of things that were partially in
the literature we also have to find an
algorithm for let's say a good algorithm
for finding the the minimal eigenvalue
of a given hamiltonian and this involves
425 pages of heavy duty calculations
generally generalizing what's known in
the literature a lot of this was done by
others and I won't really explain it
because I don't have time for it but I
do want to explain is is a way to
implement the Oracle using roughly route
em calls to a subroutine that
approximates these numbers here right
and that subroutine each one of that
subroutine would have this cost so
there's not going to be any dependence
in this runtime on these other
parameters capital or a little or an
epsilon here
perform
sorry maybe good switch over the phone
Thanks and this is this is kind of easy
to explain there's a nice geometric
argument which I'll try to do on the
next two slides so how many how many
times do we need to estimate such
quantities in order to implement the
Oracle let me remind you what we're
supposed to do here
so we have this poly calc here a set of
vectors Y which are supposed to be
non-negative m dimensional vectors and
that's just two of these linear
constraints on the vector Y and the
coefficients of this vector a in this
coefficient C they are really the
results of such trace calculations and
we know how to approximate this within
some small error by the stuff on the
previous slide now let's assume for
simplicity just for easy exposition that
that our vector Y that we're looking for
has a 1 norm equal to 1 such as the
probability distribution then what we're
really looking for is they're looking
for a vector Y such that this holds
that's just a restatement of these two
constraints here so we're really looking
for a convex combination of two
dimensional vectors BJ minus a J such
that this convex combination is at most
alpha C and it turns out that you only
need two nonzero entries in this vector
Y and it's very easy to see why I solve
those show on the next slide so remember
our goal is to find a probability
distribution Y such that this holds and
everything here is really just a
two-dimensional problem right so you
have this this vector alpha minus C here
let's say it's here it could be in each
of the four quadrants but I'll just
explain one case so let's say that it's
here and then we have this bunch of
points BJ - AJ there's M of such points
so this is the area where we want our
convex combination to end up with
because of this constraint and here's a
bunch of points so the first
two-dimensional vector could be here the
second one could be here the third one
could be here etc and our goal is to
find some convex combination that lies
in this blue region now the good thing
here is that if you want to find two
points among these M black points such
as their convex combination lies in this
region then if such a convex combination
is going to exist you can actually
separately find this point by finding
the point that makes a smallest
let's say between let's say where this
angle here between the rest points the
black points and this line is smallest
and you can separately find another
point here that minimizes the angle
between this line the red point and the
black point so what this shows two
things it shows that you only need two
nonzero entries in your vector Y and it
also shows that you can find those two
entries separately right if you consider
this as a search over over pairs of
points that would be M Squared pairs of
points and growver would use the square
root of that at runtime that's a naive
application of growver so what it shows
is that you can just use two separate
Grover's each in order root M steps to
actually find this point separately at
this point separately right so this is
just to illustrate these these different
angles that all these points make and
we're just looking for one point that
minimizes this angle and another point
that minimizes this angle and if you
find those two points which you can do
with two separate minimum findings you
find your convex combination and you
actually have a y very sparse Y that you
can spit out as a solution to your
Oracle right let's put this all together
so let's say that H is the Hamiltonian
that we have at a certain point in our
in our in our algorithm so it's going to
be D sparse it's got it's not going to
be as sparse because it will be the sum
of a bunch of s sparse matrices so D
will be bigger than s here as I said we
can estimate these traces in this many
steps and our Oracle can find a two
sparse matrix by in this many runs of
the subroutine that computes these
traces approximately so this HT it
contains two additional s sparse
matrices in each iteration we're adding
to a J's to it so it's sparsity will go
be like order T times s if you fill in
these parameters and you run this
algorithm for this many iterations this
is your run time right so this large
polynomial degree has been reduced to
eight now which is still not great but
it's better than what it was before and
for a special case of linear programs we
can improve this a little bit further
there you get a power five which is
starting to get in the range where
things might be interesting there's one
big downside of this whole Arikara
approach and that is that
so the dual solutions why that you
produce they're obtained by adding two
nonzero entries in each iteration right
so if you have capital T iterations the
vector Y that you're going to end up
with will be 2t sports that's created
principle because you can store sparse
vectors efficiently but it's not so
great if you care about let's say if you
know that for some reason all the
optimal dual solutions need to be very
dense right if you're dealing with the
problem and such problem certainly
exists where only nearly optimal dual
feasible wise are very dense then this
method will require a lot of iterations
so this is a clear limitation of of
everything that's based on these primal
dual methods with sparse vectors so I
don't know how much time I have I'm
basically talking for two minutes ok
good ok this is essentially my last
slide apart from the summary so let me
just give summarizes so in addition to
upper bounds we also have a lower bounds
as they've ground our lines for a so
they had a lower bound of square root of
n plus square root of M on the how
efficiently you can solve an SDP and in
their case all the other parameters are
of constants so this you can really
compare with the upper bound in terms of
N and M and we give a different lower
bound it looks like this and this is a
lot stronger so this becomes Omega M
times n when m and n are roughly the
same it even holds for linear programs
and you might complain now like didn't I
just show you an algorithm with an upper
bound of square root of MN that's true
but the dependence on the other
parameters is kind of hidden here so for
us the other parameters are not all
constant so really what this is showing
is you cannot get a square root and
algorithm without also having a
polynomial dependence on all these other
parameters here right in our case the
polynomial dependence was power aides I
can't show that that is optimal but you
need some polynomial dependence relief
for it letters and I must catch the
proof here but it's a reduction from a
query problem so you can define a
boolean function f which is the majority
of a bunch of or functions that each
themselves depends on a bunch of
majority functions and somehow you can
take such a binary inputs to such a
function f and you can define on this
you can define a sparse SVP well the
entries of the relevant matrices depends
very easily on the bits of the input to
F and solving that SDP would compute
this function f and then you can use
these known query complexity lower
bounds for such functions to compute to
derive query complexity lower bounds for
solving SD Peaks and this doesn't match
our algorithm so there's this work to be
done here
let me just summarize so we improved
parts of brandeis Florez quantization of
the Aurora Karl ast piece over and our
upper bound is this better behaved than
before but still not very well behaved
this power of eight is really bad we
prove the lower bound it looks like this
unfortunately when some of the other
parameters in particular capital or a
little are not constant and there's many
open questions here this is really work
in progress so one thing is you actually
want to find SDPs where this this
constant algorithm is good whether the
the advantage or the speed-up you get in
m and n is actually better than the
slowdown that you get in all these other
parameters so we would like to find s
VPS
where this guy here is small so that our
quantum algorithm actually beats
possible algorithms so you can you can
create those artificially but it would
be nicer to have some some SDP
corresponding to a good combinatorial
optimization problem where you can
actually get a speed-up we don't have
good examples of that yet we can also
try to use our techniques in very
specialized Oracle's so if you look at
the Oracle I work what they really do is
they don't do this sort of general SDP
solving they have very specialized
Oracle's that are designed for
particular combinatorial optimization
problems like Mike Scott's and and other
problems
that's another direction we should go
into we also should improve our lower
bound so I think it should be possible
to prove the square root MN lower bounds
for the case where all the other
parameters or constants they don't have
to do that but I think it's feasible and
finally and this is a broader and let's
say very general question what about
speed-up for other methods for solving
semi-desert programs or more generally
convex optimization problems in
particular are there ways to speed up
interior point methods right so you can
sort of give a physics interpretation to
interior point methods and it might be
possible to improve those as well on the
quantum computer so everyone's a little
bit over time
you sort of thank you hmm
[Applause]
great thank you other questions for
Rummel yes hi I was just wondering if
you could give some more intuition about
where this h comes from and I mean it
sort of looks miraculous that those guys
on thermal state in Aurora Carly and is
this their other you referred to this as
being a special case of another method
so are there are other places for this
similar sort of thing arises other
algorithms yeah so this is general class
of methods that are called
multiplicative weights updates this is
the the special case for matrices more
generally those are just just used for
vectors so there's a use a lot for
instance in in machine learning there's
something called there's a whole suite
of so-called boosting methods they're
all based on this method the way to
think about is I think so you should
think of this matrix empty as sort of
correcting your Hamiltonian H in the
right direction and of course you don't
really want to correct your your
Hamiltonian H you really want to correct
your role in the right direction but if
you think about this this here
so forget about non commutativity of
matrices for the moment if you change
this this matrix by adding very small
matrix to it that's kind of let's say
let's small matrix m that's kind of like
multiplying the whole matrix with
identity plus m if you ignore all the
non commutativity right so if you think
of em as sort of the direction you want
to change into
or maybe the direction you want to
change away from if it's negative then
that's what's what's happening here so
there's a small correction being added
to the exponent which you can think of
as a small correction of the matrix row
itself in the right direction which
means away from the wrong direction so
so somehow if you think of M and P as
sort of a big big violated constraints
like if I constraint or maybe some
combination of constraints it has been
massively violated by the previous row
and you're trying to move away from that
violation that's essentially what's
here great so I have a question around
the degrees you have degree 8 here and
you're bound and you know it needs some
polynomial degree do you have any
intuition or any indications of what
that degree might be that's a good
question we thought about as long and
hard I think our lower bound only shows
that it's at least 1 over 8 which is
kind of maybe 1 over 4 it's kind of
embarrassing lilo so what is the true
answer here if I have to guess I would
probably say 2 or 4 but I'm just
speculating I don't have any evidence
for that I think 2 would be kind of nice
maybe you could get into a regime where
you can actually start beating classical
s VPN ok well let's think reload again
[Applause]
and next up we have during one time and
he's going to tell us about some new
distillation protocol
okay thanks Jen one go ahead thank you
marijuana for Microsoft Research
carpeting and I'll talk about the
distillation algorithm so the motivation
for this work largely comes from a from
a proposal that Microsoft is pursuing -
it's about mer mer in our architecture
there is a theoretical proposal that we
can if you can build a network of metal
wires where the where there are Mariner
0 Modi at the end then there are some
clever ideas to implement all the
clifford gates and the big advantage
here is that you can do to all the poly
operators the high rotations along any
three of the axes simply by bookkeeping
where you have to measure and then a
header more than phase gate can be done
in a similar fashion and in the end all
the clipper keys end up being in a
fermion parity measurement and the what
is good about this is that you're
effectively implementing the breeding of
Maryland zero modes which are expected
to be protected meaning that your gate
ability will be very high there is not
typically obtaining off in other
architecture and
yes well that's what I all said yeah you
know vibrating Moroni zero you're
effectively implementing the unitary
shown above and by tuning were combining
with the measurement you can input the
full CLE first group now what's left for
the universal quantum computation as we
all very well know is the so-called key
gate what's at a gate
it's a PI over four rotation on the
Bloch sphere it comes with two different
matrices on the left you have a usual
Diana called diagonal form on the right
you have a Clifford conjugated form
which is all real in the main method to
implement this gate in the Mariner
architecture used to is to induce the
effective Hamiltonian so you increase
the coupling between two modes and wait
some time and that decouple them and the
wait time is your tuning parameter for
your T gate and the resolution of your
race time theater means the gate
fidelity of the ticket but it is
unreasonable to expect that we can
time-resolved say 10 to the minus 15
although atomic one can achieve that but
is we have to do it very frequently so
it's unreasonable to expect that we can
tune the timing data accurately so what
can we do well we can employ some
dynamic decoding technique to here but
it is not Garrett well the one of the
main assumptions in the dynamic
decoupling is that your noise model must
be very smooth other in other words you
must be a low frequency noise which is
not always the case so we better resort
to some error correcting technique so
let me just remind you I believe all of
you knew very well that the basic
principle of all tolerance you just
simulate what you want to implement with
the result redundancy here's an
oversimplified example that is a is now
even quantum so you prepare three bits
and then encode zero and one two three
bits by repeating a symbol three times
and if I want to flip the if I want to
transfer transform between two logical
bits considering
one then all you have to do is a three
or all at once and you are allowed to
make mistake as long as your mistake is
bounded by just one time then you can
look at the other two bits and correct
the one mistake you have made and the
probability of having a two or more
errors is correctly smaller than the
probability you will make a one here so
you have some fault tolerance and the
overhead from this redundancy is is well
known to be very small in the
theoretical sense that theorem goes like
that there is a some positive constant
which may be ten to the minus five or
three depending on the error model and
the architecture your catenary but and
given the N so there is a constant
depending on architecture such that
whatever gates layout of quantum gates
you give me I can convert it I can
simulate that quantum gate using a
slightly larger code how how large there
is a multiplicative poly logarithmic
factor so it's only poly log so
theoretically everything is fine but
what if the poly log battery is a 10 to
the 10 to the 10 then we should really
consider what we should do yeah in some
estimate using the surface code indeed
it tells us that like 95% of all
available qubits should be devoted to
that poly log vector so reducing that
overhead is very crucial in any
practical
advance so this talk the magic
legislation is about to reduce that
overhead so well I mean now again remind
you how we do that let's roll back and
the study the basic principle of any
measurement or any quantum algorithm
what you do you want to measure the
bottom qubit whether it is plus or minus
state in other words whether it is along
the plus XP or minus X
direction what you do with you prepare
and select cubed on the content on the
top the plus stayed here and you
entangle them using a C not and you
measure the insula the entangling gate
is supposed to transfer the phase
information here to the answer left and
this is the at the heart of any quantum
measurement including the most important
area where the mobile phase estimation
and using a similar philosophy or
similar spirit I would say we can
implement the peak each using a similar
method if you prepare a special state
called the magic state which is a
specifically this one and you bring
another qubit that you want to operate
the ticket and you entangle them and you
measure the well in this case target not
the source but it's a matter of
technicality you measure that and the
resulting state is either the t gate
applied to the original one or some
Clifford rotated version of that and you
either a measurement outcome on the
target you know which one is implemented
so you can't correctly implement T all
we need is just as a control node meant
and measurement and some Clifford
correction and we get the what we get
the desired gate and the biggest
advantage is that the preparation knows
that this magic state can be done
offline you don't have to do it online
so you have a some completely separated
factory to manufacture this key gate and
then you can inject your T state into
your opponent algorithm and the basic
principle for the distillation is that
taking enough resource out yeah it can
be large but enough resource to improve
the fidelity of this state as long as
these Clifford keys are good which we
are expected in the modern architecture
then the overall quality of my KD is
depending on the quality of light magic
state
and here the Uniting sources what I
mentioned the 95% of they're all qubits
available so what do we do we prepare
some noisy ones like has about and then
we distill to get a good one in small
number there has been a broadly speaking
two categories of the algorithm one is
to make a good one out of bad ones and
the other one is check if it's good so
and then only use those are guaranteed
that are checked to be good let me
review the first one first it was
proposed by Rob young to tell you well
the purpose of this paper is not about
actually measured logistic distillation
but to show that if you had only ideal
Clifford gates then by using this estate
injection method you can implement the
quantum universe or quantum computation
but it has also a practical ingredient
in it the basic principle is the same as
before we do the t-kid redundantly so
that we can correct or detect later and
more technical level what you do is you
prepare a special logical state built
out of some sterilizer code and then you
apply a tea cage transversely every date
the same gate or all over the fiscal
qubit and then the structure of your
encoded cube encoded logical capability
allows you to mix that your transfer
circuit becomes a logical gate so then
well provided such a code the algorithm
is straightforward apply transversal T
on the encoded plus state and look for
error because it is error correcting
code you are allowed to on the for air
without disturbing the actual state and
start over if it is bad and then if you
catch X good and you you convert the
encoded it into actual a single qubit
state then you have a better TK
and here the encode estate is turns out
to be this complicated
rowspan of this particular matrix the
what's special about this matrix is that
every row has eight ones well there are
15 columns but every row has eight ones
and whatever linear combination you take
out of these four rows
you always get a nonzero vector whose
rate is always paint so that special
eight is a requirement now well we know
that this exists but this particular
matrix matrix such that any real
combination has a multiple of eight wait
is hard to find that's why I drove this
well metaphorically I'd wrote this you
the fractal structure is not appearing
in inning any fashion but in some
special fashion yeah and they're the
second category whether it is good it
was actually written in a one paragraph
of Neil's paper that had that actually
appeared there like at two months before
Bradley and Tyus but largely ignore the
letters reference for some reason I
don't know
he wrote that a straightforward way to
decrease Phi PI over a state the T State
is to use Delta dual CSS code for
encoding one ship it with the good error
detecting properties and he mentions
that there is a seven cubed Hamming code
so let me decipher what he means by that
so well so we want to measure the
eigenvalue of some operator whose
eigenstate is my magic state so well let
me give you the easier example
non-relevant actually irrelevant example
but easier to understand suppose I want
to have a state pointing plus direction
in C basis but what do i do bring me any
state i measure in the Z basis and if
it's plus then I'm guaranteed that my
state is in the
State so being able to measure in that
basis guarantees my guarantee allows me
to prepare that basis but magic state is
an eigenstate of hedemark which is not
how a operator so the measurement
circuit is not in the Clippard group so
here's our attribute this is my magic
state and this is my hat amarte and this
is much not like there's equation for
the magic state so it becomes a problem
how to measure in the h basis and Neil
in the same paper wrote this circuit in
order to measure the hata mark you
should implement the control data Mart
with the angela prepared in the
x-direction the with the thing 90 same
people same principle goes along here we
read off the phase from the target to
the source by by applying entangling aid
so this is the Integra gate and that is
a target as my Angela so we will read
out the some phase information here and
transfer to the insula from this control
element and control how to mark can be
implemented if I were if I if I were
provided with the 2t state magic gate so
I want to measure in the H phases to
prepare T state but in order to do that
I need another 2t state so the argument
sounds a circular so it sounds
contradictory but it's not self
contradiction because we have a we don't
aim for the perfect metric state but
some good approximation for that the
trick is to think of an aircraft and
code where the Helen Marty is
transversal so implementing Hadamard on
at the physical level becomes a logical
data Mart so if I so here's the circuit
bring me no ET gate
encode well embed this noise ETA into
the logical space of my error correcting
code on which if I apply a transversal
hedemark then it becomes the logical
Hanuman
so yeah so if I implement control
hedemark
across all the physical qubits then this
whole circuit becomes the control
Hadamard on the logical level but since
this is inside an error-correcting code
therefore I'm allowed to make a mistake
so even though you make a mistake in the
in the middle there's a chance that you
will detect right so in bed implemented
control Hadamard noisy one and then
check if it's good if it's good and
output that's the basic principle and
this has been used in the another in
another code using a smaller number of
qubits so previously we used eight total
qubits including the measuring insula
but here we're using only five so the
basic principle you look is a saying we
prepare a four cubed code where the
transversal hedemark becomes some
logical operation at the logical level
and then we massage that a logical
operation to test the eigenvalue of the
Hadamard so this works great because it
uses very small number of physical
qubits which is scarce resource the
scaling is not as good as the previous
one because it's only quadratic
suppression rather than a cubic
suppression but we can do it over and
over again to achieve the desired
accuracy goal how do we do the
repetition the world typical approach is
the county concatenation you prepare a
bunch of noisy ones in the use use one
of the protocols in the previous slide
to make a slightly better one keep
running your factory and then collect
the output up from those Factory and put
them another next stage factory to
produce to a single one as you can see
as the number of concatenation growth
grows then the number of input gates
grows exponentially at the slightly
faster lab a faster rate than the
the error rate in crews one one concern
from this idea is that well it works
effectively very well but it typically
requires a large number of physical
qubits and it is well although although
all the factories that the first-level
runs in parallel at the time you're
running at the second Factory a lot of
qubits must be an idle so instead we
take the second approach where we retest
the magic speed to our satisfaction so
we observe that there's a large class of
quantum codes that admits transfers
ahead of art that we call inner code and
we are the main conclusion is that any
weekly self-dual codes can be used for
this purpose what we need is that
transfers I had a mark becomes illogical
hedemark that's it you know in the end
the theorem is that for any CSS code
where the transfers I had them are
either logical up here I don't care what
logical operator it is if it is logical
down on fine then there is a choice of
logical qubits not every logical qubit
choice will work but there we show there
exist some logical qubit choice such
that either either it satisfies my goal
or it can implement something similar
that I can turn you into a logical
kallenberg and if this involves the
classification of symmetric forms over
the binary field let me show you in the
next slide how to do that and since our
requirement is only weakly self dual
code meaning it's the transfers Hadamard
is exactly a logical operator this
allows us to use virtually any code
because any stabiliser code you
represent it with the myrin operators
and they interpret that as a stabilizer
code again so by doubling by doubling
the physical number were actually by
multiplying forward to the number of
physical qubits you can always obtain
with such a weekly self 201 and the
special symmetry requirement as we have
seen before in the 15 to 1 a protocol
where every linear combination of the
rows of a binary matrix has to be has to
have a weight multiple of 8 that
requirement is gone it's much relaxed
criterion so there's a abundance of
codes available so here is the promised
classification of binary forms why the
why the symmetric form appears since
we're focusing on the weakly self-dual
one there's an x-pipe stabilizer and the
z-type stabilizer there are one-to-one
correspondence there they correspond to
the same bit string and more abstractly
it corresponds to a several thousand a
subspace of of my binary vector space so
you going through the CSS construction I
get the number of in collectivities
being this formula number of total
physical qubits - imagine of this
several thousand subspace then if you
look at the X or detail logical
operators that corresponds to the
orthogonal complement of this s and
there there is an inner product in this
quotient space that controls the
commutation relation between X and Z
operator and this this inner product is
symmetric in its argument so that's why
we classified by a symmetric forms over
the binary field if it turns out that
there are only two classes one in one
class you have a you can find a basis
where where it consists of all the
weight vectors but mutually it's all our
dollars in the other basis they form a
direct sum of hyperbolic planes there
are only two choices and nothing more
the first choice will implement under
the head of art the logical head
emergent on every cubic simultaneously
and the second choice it implements
control is what's a swab off the I'm
sorry the physical level transfers and
other might be terms of suavo operation
is a lot
to level but we can massage that to turn
into a Heather mark checking operation
so here's the overall algorithm we what
we want to do is measure the tensor K
tensor product of Hadamard logical
operator and we'll post the legs on the
plus one outcome on that eigenvalue
measurement and the implementation of
the Hadamard tensor k will be done by
some inner code any weekly self dual
code and inherently it gives the wrong
answer with a small probability because
there's a chance that two of the tickets
conjugating the control x is faulty
whose air and the pair of them will
propagate to the insula and gives my
measurement album will be flipped so
that's an inherent and another
possibility is that some combination of
errors on the t gauge will become a
natural logical error on the my code and
that that will that will pollute my
magic state so that happens with the
peach of the d where these the code
distance of my weekly self-dual
scissors code which can be arbitrarily
large by choosing a clever one but this
one being quadratic that I make I always
measure the wrong eigen value is
inherent in this idea but this one is
easy to fix because I can repeat so if
you are familiar if you want to feed
some quantum Channel notation then it
looks like this
so given a row it mostly almost always
projects onto the even parity subspace
of this case tensor products of H and
sometimes makes mistakes so that it
project onto the odd appearance of space
and sometimes to some nasty thing at the
order D
and to cope with the inherent problem
that with the p2 the pits of a square
probability needs a measurement error we
just repeat but we don't just repeat we
cleverly repeat and that specification
how we repeat is encoding in this outer
code so the the role of the outer code
is to specify which cubed I should check
in so here's an example I want to check
the parity of this for input Magic
States and suppose I have one wrong one
then by repeating four measurements
along specified by these circles I can
detect this error and the probability I
will miss this error will be P to the
fourth because I will I well this single
arrow should have violated two checks at
least so here comes the assessed concept
of a sensitivity of our outer code so
it's a kind of classical code but the
parity check matrix itself is very
important because here I could have
implemented the repetition code by by
measuring only three but the fourth one
was was inserted to ensure and to
correct my inherent measurement errors
and that we call the sensitivity so in a
short the sufficient criterion is that
my parity check matrix for my outer code
should satisfy this inequality for any
nonzero error of extra e so this is for
the this is the this party is the usual
KO distance of your classical code and
the first term is to account the fact
that I make mistake
and the we can provide some sufficient
condition for the outer code from some
graph theoretic construction in interest
it turns out that any the adjacency
matrix of any by regular bipartite graph
of growth large growth has a set it
should always satisfy this so the
adjacent matrix is directly this M so
suppose I if I have a if I represent the
cube is to be checked as a left walk
left two nodes and the measurement
routines I implement to be the right
node and the degree of on the right is
going to be the number of encoded qubits
on my stabilizer code degree on the left
is that by the sensitivity requirement
so if if this graph has large earth then
I'm good to go
so here comes a to theorems the one
verbal version of our theorem is that
with codes the weekly sales tool
CSS code whose including rate is near
one such code exists then roughly
speaking only the magic States the rough
one is required to suppress the air to
to give power so it's probably we
conjecture that it's all team although
we don't have any lower bound actually
there is no lower bound in the in the
literature a surprising fact that such a
basic problem has not been decided so in
a more formal language for any odd D
greater than equal to five and it's some
real number the average number of magic
state input measure state is only D plus
Delta and the error rate goes down by
Goethe power you can also save some
space by using this technique not
considering the weekly self-dual codes
with the including rating year one but
some good family of weekly acceptable
code meaning that at distancing the
number of physical qubits is only
constant times B in a number of encoded
cubed logical qubits is also ordered
thee using those codes combined with a
random outer codes you can achieve that
you only require order D cube is in
total nothing else it consumes d squared
th and produces order D States out with
the error rate suppress evil if you if
you use the concatenated routine then
the space overhead would would be B to
the some exponent greater than one per
output and is well if you are thinking
with the code that outputs as a single
one the exponent has not been reduced
below two
let me remark before I finish this this
problem has a lot of measures to
consider and we have not covered them
all we mainly focused on the space
requirement that's why we focused on the
second category where we check and
meditate on to our satisfaction rather
than concatenating and the we have
assumed that Clifford gates are perfect
but which is not always the case so we
should consider their circuit depth and
overall Clifford count as well and we
don't want the qubits to be idling too
much so the parallel eyes ability
another criterion to consider and of
course if the tea naive take it even
though it's noisy one is expensive then
we have to reduce that number I know and
this protocols does not always succeed
it rejects some of the inputs so we
should consider it the success
probability not to be too small we want
them to be near one and of course the
output quality must be as good we only
have covered a few part of it like the
first one and in the input T account but
all the other performance measures is to
be analyzed further in of course we have
to consider some tolerance about
imperfect clifford's how he propagates
and how it affects the output pH quality
so before this is the second to last
slide here are some examples the yellow
if the orange ones are from our idea and
the other ones are existing ones if you
look at the space requirement per output
then obviously this one first the best
ammonia requires this is for further
reduction in error but only requires
like a three cubits per output physical
health and physical qubit I mean in the
he counts the number of non-preferred
gates that are to be injected into the
system is order of eleven which is quite
small number in comparison to others
I think I would just skip that part and
let me just summarize and conclude so
the distillation efficiency is going to
be the clock speed setter in in in a
prominent well in the prep in the
prevalent architecture as involved in
any satellizer codes so optimizing this
rotini is very important for
practicality and also a theoretical
interest because we don't have a lower
bound yet and our approach can use
virtually any stabilizer code because we
have reduced the symmetry requirement by
one level or and this family comes with
the it can be adjusted very flexibly it
doesn't require a single code that works
for one but we have a know a lot of room
to play with and it includes some
smaller size instances that works on a
small number of physical qubits which
might be important in practice let me
conclude there thanks for attention
great thank you other questions for Jen
one
that was great
very interesting could you go back to
your table I'm just curious
yes sir this like higher order ones so I
should read that as I need 840 input
t-gates
like bad two gates to get 11 now you
mean so that is the number of T is the
number of T's in the circuit yeah total
number piece and then what would screw
us what your opinion is on these ideas
of mixing codes like you know
concatenated 15 cubed code with 7 cubed
code to get sort quality transversal T
gates do you think in the end do you
think that's a thread distillation or
will distillation always be better
ah that's a hard question I don't know
the answer but well if you just care
about the TKD efficiency then the code
switching approach typically requires
the to the cubed number of physical
qubits whereas here is roughly well it's
that there is a hard to compare but the
physical number of cubes is much less
here if well provided that the Clippers
are good
the other question not posting Nathan
with accurate next great listening to
Jung won again for a great talk
[Applause]
great so up next we have Nathan and
Nathan is going to tell us about a new
approach for quantum chemistry around a
plane wave dual basis great
all right so okay cool well thank you
very much
looks like the clicker is remote got
taken so I'm going to have to be doing
some bouncing back and forth I apologize
and I doubly apologize for those of you
who've read the the program because
unfortunately there will be no talk
about bars in here and this I apologize
but yes unfortunately it will be Basie's
instead
blame autocorrect so basically what the
idea is behind this this talk is I mean
what we really want to do is we want to
do quantum simulation as cheaply as
possible on a quantum computer why is
that
well quantum simulation really from my
perspective is arguably the most natural
application of quantum computing because
if you look at it at a high level a
quantum computer is fundamentally a
programmable quantum system capable of
implementing any dynamics permitted by
the laws of quantum mechanics and so it
naturally makes sense that well if
you've got some dynamical process in
nature why not just program the quantum
computer to emulate that that's entirely
the the intuition behind quantum
simulation over the years a host of
increasingly more complex or simple
depending on your perspective methods
have been devised in order to actually
compile unitary dynamics into
fundamental operations at the quantum
computer can execute but actually it's
only recently that that I feel some of
the biggest advances have happened and
ironically I feel that these advances
aren't necessarily entirely from the
perspective of our advances that would
come from the perspective of theoretical
computer science one of the big changes
that we've we've had is have started
coming about the question of well
alright it's great to have a quantum
simulator but really why do we want a
quantum simulator what actually are the
things we want to simulate and what
pieces of information do we really want
to extract and this has led us to ask
questions about you know what how would
we derive value from a quantum computer
and how
we simplify the algorithms in order to
extract these pieces of information and
so things we would want to do is
typically the thing most thing we're
most interested in from for quantum
chemistry simulations isn't the dynamics
that we were interested in largely in
either the inception of quantum
computing it usually is static
properties like energy eigenvalues or
gaps because these quantities end up
giving us properties such as reaction
rates for important chemical processes
for example biological nitrogen fixation
is something that we could potentially
start to get a handle on if we had a
machine that was capable of figuring out
what the ground state energy is for
nitrogen A's similarly we could hope
hope to get some good understanding of
the mechanisms behind high temperature
superconductors by actually well just
building it on a quantum computer
simulating it and seeing if we can
extract some intuition from those
simulations so these are the sorts of
things that we would like to address and
the way that we go about doing this is
really what we want to do is we want to
kind of bridge this gap between the the
stuff that's going on inside the beaker
and a stuff inside the quantum computer
and the way that we bridge this gap is
really just by cracking open a quantum
chemistry textbook like this one though
I actually this is probably a bad choice
even though I like to cover art because
it doesn't talk about second quantized
methods very much
but anyways that is that is basically
what you do you take this chemical
system over here you find a mathematical
model from your favorite quantum
chemistry textbook and then you
implement that model inside the quantum
computer so that is actually entirely
how I almost all of the simulations have
gone we've talked to the chemists
figured out what they like to do and
they kind of you know done some quantum
yoga in order to bend over backwards and
get the quantum computer in order to fit
what's convenient for the chemists so
what do these encoding actually look
like well to get some idea the simplest
way that we can do this or at least the
most concise
way in terms of representing chemistry
or electronic structure more generally
in a quantum computer is using the
second quantized representation as it's
known and basically all this ends up
doing is it says alright what I'm going
to do is I'm going to break up this
molecule and represent the positions the
electrons can be in using a discrete
basis so I consider just a discrete set
of molecular orbitals that could
describe how the electrons are going
about in order to represent the wave
function so here's an example let's say
you know I wanted to describe this
molecule over here and I picked you know
a bunch of different basis vectors over
here what I do is I say okay I now will
occupy these individual basis vectors by
Counting how many electrons are in them
now okay we have this thing called a
Pauli exclusion principle so the nice
thing is we don't have to count very
high we only have to go between 0 and 1
because you can't fit two electrons in a
single orbital and this is really
convenient because what it means is we
can actually just imagine each of these
molecular orbitals in this
representation as a single qubit so all
we do is we just keep track of whether
there's an electron there or whether
they're eight and so for example this
over here we would represent this as a
qubit string 1 1 this one over here is 0
1 because all of these are unoccupied
they'd be 0 0 and that's it you might
wonder hey aren't these guys aren't
electrons anti-symmetric don't you have
to worry about all of that stuff turns
out with this representation it's really
nice because in second quantized
pictures you don't actually have to
worry about anti symmetry I think it's
already been done for you so that
problem is actually already handled just
by the definition of this so we can
easily write down quantum wave functions
and easily evolve and do everything with
it and that's one of the reasons that
they're so attractive to represent in
this form so
basically the way the whole path that we
end up doing for for simulation is that
first thing we do is we begin by getting
some configuration getting some molecule
over here and then we prepare qubits in
this in order to represent the problem
then what we do is we kind of add these
over here supposed to be representing
kind of molecular orbitals so if you
imagine this being like a local basis
that we're using for this these could be
something like gaussians that we set up
in order to approximate the electron
density for so we go through we end up
constructing a finite basis to describe
to us and then we compile the dynamics
ie
the interactions between electrons at
these various sites into a sequence of
quantum gates that would describe you
know the repulsion that they would have
between each other for example okay and
there's a bunch of different ways we can
do it charter Suzuki methods are
provided the first and probably easiest
way to think about it and then well in
the end we've got to extract some piece
of information from it a piece of
information you want to extract of
course depends on your problem but
typically the way that we will we'll do
this is using phase estimation because
phase estimation gives you the answer
with quadratically less work than other
methods so that's basically the entire
tool chain we begin by you know
preparing some initial state ideally it
should be close to the the ground state
if you want to measure ground state
energy ideally then you compile into
into a dynamical simulation that you use
that inside a phase estimation circuit
to learn the spectrum all right and so
basically the question is well what does
a Hamiltonian end up looking like the
disks I talked about the basic process I
talked about how to encode States using
this but I didn't talk about what the
dynamics ends up looking like and that
actually leads to one of the biggest
challenges of quantum chemistry
simulation in particular because if we
end up having our Coulomb Hamiltonian
when we compile it into these creation
and annihilation operators that describe
the hopping that each of the electrons
could have between the orbitals that
represent the problem
what we end up seeing is that we have
something that looks like this that goes
up to the fourth order in these creation
and annihilation operators and this guy
over here is where the bulk of the
complexity ends up coming from so you
know this over here says if we've got n
terms or n different orbitals in it then
the number of terms in our Hamiltonian
scales like n to the fourth right which
actually that can be pretty significant
in some cases and this ends up having a
direct impact on the complexity of the
simulation so if we take a look at the
best results that we end up having at
the moment asymptotically speaking then
the complexity of simulating the
dynamics for these methods ends up going
like n to the fifth for these if I
exclude logarithmic factors from it now
that actually doesn't sound that that
bad but the problem is in order to do
molecules that we find interesting and
roughly speaking has to be greater than
100 in order to have a chance of beating
classical methods which are already
pretty good to be honest actually
they've gotten so good it's kind of
intimidating it turns out if you use
modern quantum chemistry techniques on
the computers of the 1950's you actually
would come out ahead
compared to using the quantum chemistry
techniques of the 1950s on modern
computers so actually quantum chemistry
techniques have been improving faster
than Moore's law so we have to go
embarrassingly far out like 100 plus
qubits often in order to be able to
actually be able to beat some of these
methods so this creates an issue and oh
yeah this doesn't work so if we go
through and actually figure out roughly
speaking the number of gates that we
need and these are somewhat pessimistic
assumptions I'll say and again if these
aren't new results I talked about them
last year the faculty summit but the
best estimates we have to solve a
problem that we know is important then
that we strongly suspect it's hard for
classical computers we seem to need at
most about 10 to the 14 days all right
now it turns out if you've got a fast
quantum computer you can actually fly
through those gates
in a sensible amount of time but if we
don't have a fast quantum computer or we
need a ton of error correction then this
can actually be this can be quite
punitive so we'd really really like to
get these numbers down but a big
challenge behind this is that a lot of
this complexity comes from the fact that
we just have so goddamn many terms in
our Hamiltonian and that's something the
physics gives us it's hard to imagine
how in many ways to optimize against
this in the indie algorithms themselves
there are some techniques but they're
kind of limited like coalescing for
example so in our work we take a very
different approach rather than kind of
doing this you know this yoga stuff and
bending over backwards and saying let's
take a Gaussian basis that the that the
chemists know and love and then compile
that to run on a quantum computer let's
actually take a look at the
representations for the electronic
structure that we can find that are best
for a quantum computer and solve those
so that's the idea behind this and
that's why we chose we decided to use a
plain way of dual basis for this problem
because this basis is incredibly good
for quantum chemistry simulations on a
quantum computer it's useful in some
cases in the classical setting but it's
really really good in the quantum
setting so that's basically the idea so
the basic there's two bases that that
our message end up playing with a plane
wave basis and a plane wave dual basis
all right and so the basic idea behind
this is that the the simplest intuition
for this problem is to take a look at a
periodic class imagine you've got a
lattice of atoms stretching stretching
out and what we'd like to do is we'd
like to take a look at what sort of the
natural functions are for this and one
of the things to note is that if we've
got a periodic lattice then the
potential also is periodic if the
potential is periodic then of course if
we're an infinite lattice the wave
function should be periodic as well so
it makes sense then in order to be able
to represent these in terms of periodic
functions
like plane waves that go through this
and these plane waves they can all be
described by their momentum vector K
over here so that's the idea
instead of using localized gaussians
centered around particular sites we
expand our electronic potential in terms
of these guys over here
and so that's that's basically it now
there's some pros ones are some cons to
it ultimately we're going to see that
this will simplify the Hamiltonian a con
is that if you have a kind of localized
electron density then you're going to
need more more plane waves in order to
be able to describe this then you would
need with a specially tuned Gaussian
basis for large systems there's their
results saying is that that plane waves
are nearly optimal you can't
asymptotically do better than plane
waves to describe things but for finite
size problems there's good reasons to
suspect that there may be trade-offs
between these methods but there's other
favorable things about that that makes
me suspect that this will actually be
useful for very very small ones as well
so just to give you an idea about how
this works okay
we'd like to represent everything in
terms of plane waves but we don't have
all it we can't represent all infinity
plane waves obviously so we have to pick
we have to pick them in a somewhat a
smart way and the natural most natural
way we thought in order to represent
this is just to imagine taking a look at
momentum space in in 3d and just really
breaking it up into a bunch of cubes all
our orbitals now can really just be
thought of as the single momentum vector
specified by a KX @ KY and KZ at one of
these center grid points so those are
all of our molecular orbitals and oh
we're just going to have hopping terms
in our Hamiltonian just like we had
before that caused electrons to move
between these different sites all right
and so how does this end up helping
because you'd imagine naively we should
still have the same K to the fourth
scaling right because everything to talk
to everything else everything can
scatter off of everything else but that
isn't actually quite the fully the case
the reason why is because momentum has
to be conserved
in in any interaction so what that means
is that means that if you have two plane
waves or two two things colliding with
each other
we know that the momenta they had before
has to be equal to the moment that they
have after for any legal interaction so
though their words end to the fourth
choices before coming in conservation
and momentum eliminates a lot of those
choices and now we only have order and
cubed terms in our Hamiltonian when we
simplify it after using this constraint
so this already shows the kinds of
simplifications that that we can get out
of this
so first yeah so here in this in this
particular case what we have is we've
made we're making okay it's a very good
question
particularly one of the things I didn't
go into is we're assuming a periodized
Coulomb operator so even though we do
allow electronic interaction like nuclei
in the problem we assume that they're
all periodized
so all of this is taking place on the
last we can do chemistry here as opposed
to you know materials but we have to
take the limit as our unit cells end up
going increasing and that's another
drawback of our approach but in this
period eyes approach momentum is
manifestly conserved yes exactly so okay
so that's that's basically the idea so
we just by doing this alone we can get
down to n cubed from n to the fourth
which is nice and it's still not an
effective theory like you would see with
a Hubbard bottle or something like that
this is real electronic structure but n
cubed is already is actually too bad for
us we wanted to do even better so we
decided well let's look at this further
and we decided it we realized that what
we can do is we can look at a plane wave
dual basis now intuitively the plane
wave dual basis is actually really
straightforward it's sort of almost like
the position representation of it so
what we do is we take the plane waves
that we have in the original basis and
we just apply a discrete Fourier
transform to it which morally speaking
transforms it to something
like a position basis for it and when we
end up going through that transformation
due to some nice nice cancellation that
ends up happening what we end up seeing
is that there's only order n-squared
terms that end up popping out modulo cat
a caveat about the periodic potential so
now we actually have order n squared
terms in our Hamiltonian which is a
quadratic reduction over what we would
be seeing otherwise and that that is a
big deal so how would we go about
simulating this well the way we consider
doing this is we consider we could
consider doing a simulation like this
directly by consider doing the following
what we do is we consider laying out
qubits say in a 2d lattice then what we
do is we draw a path between them now
what we have to do in order to do the
simulation is we have to simulate all of
these individual interactions and by
doing a series of swaps between them
technically they're actually fermionic
swaps you'll get through in a second
then what we can do is we can bring all
of these individual pairs near each
other and do the interactions in
parallel that way so we do a series of
fermionic swaps to move things around
and efficiently go through all of those
N squared interactions in an actual
linear in linear depth so we can do this
in on parallel quantum computer
incredibly quickly but that's actually
not the approach we you that we use to
get the best complexity out of this the
best way for us is to use this method
called the fast fermionic Fourier
transform or ffft so no that's that's
not a typo this is this is a technique
that's used in order to be able to
actually kind of do a transformation
between the plane wave basis and a dual
plane wave basis or the plane wave dual
basis and so what it is is it's just
like an ordinary discrete Fourier
transform except rather than being a
Fourier transform on the components of
some vector like you would normally see
what it is is this a Fourier transform
on the mode operators themselves so the
creation operators get mapped to a
uniform super
addition of other creation operators
okay so with appropriate phases in those
phases are just like the ones that you
would see over here so that is that is
basically the the operator that we
wanted to do and actually it had been
talked about in the passive papers by
vers trotty and others that mention how
to do it but a challenge that we ran
into is that they only worked out
explicitly how to do this for the case
of eight modes and implicitly give some
arguments that were hard to follow about
how you would actually do this and on
top of that there their approach only
ends up working even at that point use
it for the Jordan Vigny representation
of the electronic structure problem and
so we decided in part for fun to work
out how the how this works explicitly in
a basis independent way so it can be
done in any representation Robbie Kidd
have or brow these new approach as well
so anyways the reason why we want to do
this is because the fast fermionic
fourier transform what it does is it
takes this kinetic part of the
hamiltonian and allows us to write it
actually is a diagonal operator in this
this representation just like you would
see in ordinary like imagine what you
wanted to do is simulate position plus
momentum the standard way that people
would end up doing that is they'd say
okay I've got two parts I've got the
position operator which is diagonal I
could just simulate that directly the
momentum part or kinetic part is not
diagonal but I can do a Fourier
transform to make it diagonal that's
exactly what we do here but now because
their Hamiltonian is expressed in terms
of creation and annihilation operators
we can't just use the QFT
to go back and forth between the two we
have to use the FFF and that's that's
how we do it and so our it's fun because
our second quantized Hamiltonian
simulation scheme actually looks very
very similar to the first quantized
simulation schemes that were used
earlier but we don't have to worry about
anti symmetry or any of the other
headaches of that so that that's
basically how it ends up going and then
once you do this if you want to do a
Trotter simulation of it well all you
have to do is then just stroboscopic Lee
evolve under both of these different
terms so we can approximate the dynamics
is just evolution under under the
diagonal part then a short evolution
under the kinetic part and then back
under the potential again and by
repeating this rapidly enough then we
can end up simulating the dynamics
arbitrarily well so basically again the
idea behind behind this whole process is
is in order to in order to actually
circuit eyes this what you need to do is
you need to have a method for doing the
FFT so here's an example of what this
ends up looking like and it's all
predicated on the fermionic swap
operator fermionic swap operator is a
swap between two two qubits so say
you've got a lecture on here in a
lecture on there if if they were bosons
and you wanted to swap them then you
would just apply swap gate which would
switch them over but prefer me on you
get a minus sign as well so you can
think about fermionic a swap operator
it's just a swap with like a cz in
between in order to fix design but that
only works in Jordan Vigenere
representation and here's the basis
independent version of it at the top
which works for anything so that's the
fact that's how it goes and so what we
want to do what we want to do is well
after we divide a devise that we wanted
to build up a fast Fourier transform
circuit in these mode operators based on
this idea so in order to do that we
needed to protects get a two element
fermionic Fourier transform which we can
then bootstrap to do a full Fourier
transform and so brute force we went
through and managed to find a circuit
for that in terms of the fermionic swap
and everything else so this is it we can
then combine it together and we end up
finding that this for example is the
eighth element ffft and we can just
build that up to bigger bigger versions
by rehearsing it in exactly the same
ways that you
you to build the past the past for EHS
so that's how we do it and again after
doing that we continue through for
charter Suzuki simulations evolving
under the kinetic then the potential
then the kinetic then the potential
doing us over and over and again again
our times where our is some large number
to make the air small in the evolution
so the error that we end up getting for
this ends up depending on the commutator
of these particular terms and so
basically in order to bound the value of
air that we need are the number of value
var that we need what we do is we just
use standard norm inequalities for this
ie the triangle inequality figure out
how big all of those individual norms
can be put them together in the worst
case scenario we get this kind of
scaling mega over here that's the kind
of the volume of the unit cells that
you're looking at epsilon is like the
error that you want to hit eight is the
number of particles n is the number of
spin orbitals T is the evolution time so
if we put that all together then what we
end up getting is that if we assume that
we want to as we scale this thing up ie
increase the number of spin orbitals
that we keep the electron density
constant in that limit then we can
actually end up saying that the the
depth that we require for the charter
Suzuki algorithm scales like end of the
3.5 which I think is really kind of
awesome because if you take a look at
the rigorous bounds that we had for
trotter Suzuki methods before for this
admittedly we're solving in a different
basis so there are differences between
them but those rigorous bounds are into
the eighth or and this over here ends up
getting us down to the end of the three
point five and that's that's a big deal
but we don't have to there are methods
that have better asymptotic scaling in
particular linear combinations of unit
Ares can give us better better scaling
than this so we decided let's go through
and take a look at how these methods end
up scaling the idea basically behind the
simplest LCU methods is what we do is we
take a look at if you take a look at the
time evolution operator
you can really just envision the time
evolution operator is a Taylor series
like this you truncate the Taylor series
at some appropriate order and then you
just use a gadget for adding different
unit areas together in order to directly
implement this guy over here so if it
seems like it shouldn't work because
this is the dumbest expansion ever
nobody ever uses this in numerical
analysis and yet it works beautifully
well on quantum computers because of
this gadget and because of amplitude
amplification so that is basically the
idea behind it and so when we go through
it in order to use this gadget we have
to express the Hamiltonian as a sum of
unitary matrices to you to compile this
into a circuit so we just throw that
through the Jordan Vigenere
transformation our Hamiltonian becomes
this and in this case it's not even
worthwhile it turns out doing the fast
for a fermionic Fourier transform we may
as well just do the compilation and run
it we get no benefit out of doing the
FFT here and so when we go through all
of this what we end up finding is that
the total depth over here for simulation
of this Hamiltonian scales like n to the
8 over 3 again under the assumption and
as we scale up the system to more and
more spin orbitals than the density of
electrons remains the same so this
actually is kind of interesting because
if we go ahead over here it turns out
that what we're looking at n to the 3.5
over here under those assumptions
assuming at a de the number of electron
scales linearly with the number of
orbitals versus this over here which is
just a little under 3 so the gap
interestingly enough between the upper
bounds that we prove for the linear
combination methods in terms of the
scaling with N and the Trotters Suzuki
methods isn't actually all that big in
this case which is kind of you know a
family because it was nearly quadratic
before the other thing that's worth
paying attention to is the fact that the
bound technique that we use for the
Trotters Suzuki method comes up it uses
worst case
for nested commutator with each other
and often those nested commentators are
much smaller especially an expectation
value than these worst-case bounds end
up seeing so some work that you know I
did earlier with adid and others ended
up actually taking a look at these
bounds and they proved to be pessimistic
by many orders of magnitude when we use
them before on the Gaussian basis so we
strongly suspect that this scaling that
we see for a Trotter Suzuki though is
the rigorous upper bound in practice
we'll end up seeing things that are
likely much much smaller than that and
so there's ongoing work in order to
actually figure out numerically at the
very least what what this actual scaling
really is another thing that I think is
kind of interesting which is an open
question we don't know how to solve yet
at the moment is that you'll notice that
the complexity for the Trotter method
ends up scaling with the number of
electrons in the system but the linear
combination method it doesn't that part
is that part is just it's completely
oblivious the reason why is because of
the fact that with this case over here
you can argue very easily that you're
just staying inside a constant electron
manifold during the simulate during a
simulation with Trotter Suzuki and that
allows you to make some nice bounds
about how big these commentators can be
in the air' expansion but when you're
looking at the Taylor series method the
only thing that matters is the one norm
of the unitary operators or the sum of
the unitary operator coefficients that
you're adding together for that and that
doesn't care about what subspace yours
so we'd like to like to be able to
improve that and understand it so in
conclusion we by switching by changing
the way that we approach quantum
chemistry simulation to represent the
problem in a way that's convenient for a
quantum computer rather than the other
way around we've seen some huge
advantages and my hope is that by
continuing to work alongside chemists
and understand really how to best adapt
the problem they're dealing with to the
technology we're going to
that will continue to see improvements
this large or potentially larger for
broad ranges of problems thank you very
much great Thank You Nathan with our
questions for Nathan yeah so which of
the advantages of the of the dual mentum
would apply to classical quantum
computing as well as any so I think that
one of the things that would that
clearly would end up applying is that if
if you want to if you wanted to do a
okay so basically it's it is it is
actually used in a few in a few cases so
for one case if you're looking at
homogeneous or even inhomogeneous
electron gases then these bases often
are used just because of the for very
similar reasons because there's very few
terms in it and it's an exact theory
they don't have to apply a Gaussian
basis to it so they are broadly used for
that but what we're advocating is
because of the fact that it's this is so
simple for a quantum computer we feel
that even using this outside of its
comfort zone
is probably a good idea
yes I was earning the one could argue
that the artifact basis is probably the
most compact basis to represent molecule
to a given accuracy so it uses kind of
the smallest possible filter space so do
you know what kind of a hit you take by
going to this basis do you need to
increase the number of orbitals
substantially here so all right
unfortunately when it comes to this even
we understand asymptotically it's near
optimal but in the finite size cases
that we're dealing with the best that I
can deal of we could we could do was
take a look at numerical results that
people have looked at and typically at
least according to garnet chance
the main hit that you end up taking is
typically about a factor of 20 increase
in the number of orbitals to hit the
same accuracy so given a quadratic
reduction in the the scaling that's
probably still favorable so I just
wanted to ask about that quadratic
reduction so I kind of understood that
the first step was you go to plain waves
and momentum conservation gives you in
cubes and then from memory you sort of
said well you get some cancellations and
you get to N squared can you maybe
expand on like where does that win come
from is there some intuition for that
you know the truth is I don't have very
much intuition for it it for me it was
just a calculation that that we went
through in order to be able to go from
one to the other
garnet seemed to have some intuitions
that this was the right way to represent
the problem that had you know was going
to have far far fewer orbitals but yeah
at the end for up from from my
perspective it was just the calculations
but I should look at it more and see if
I can develop a deeper intuition
hi thank you um so in the in the
calculations that I'm involved in and
we've talked about these things before
and latest QCD calculations ones working
with finite boxes planet space time
volumes and when his periodic boundary
conditions or twisted boundary
conditions whatever so one of the things
we have to deal with is finite volume
effects from the particles wrapping
around the world effectively and coming
back and the typical scale for those is
set by the gaps in the spectrum so the
volumes that you're going to be working
with large enough so that these
exponentially suppressed Corrections are
tiny well actually that's something we
haven't looked at quite at the moment so
this work over here the main purpose
behind it was just to look at the
asymptotics to see how sensible this
basis was even think about doing quantum
chemistry simulation and or more
accurately material science is probably
the simplest application because the
periodicity is natural there but the
point is is that the next studies that
we're doing are actually generically
prove this out and get it get a good
intuition for how bad these finite
volume effects are actually going to be
so that's the next stage I'd love to
chat about it
defector 20 above the plane ways I
thought is more like effect of a few
hundred and you said that Ghana told you
that it's the fact of 20 so I checked
with Garnett a couple of few weeks ago
yeah and this can be fact of 20 if you
have a crystal lattice structure and you
use Neos so dr. Kidd potentials but you
only look at vinegar the conduction
bands when you look at molecules then
it's more like get back to a thousand or
so so you have to be a bit careful then
see you what makes sense in the end yeah
yeah in another comment no yeah no
debate about that this is this is likely
not going to be the one basis to rule
them all but I feel that the the message
is is that the Hamiltonian is simple
enough here that it probably does have a
little bit more reach beyond what we
would think and the second point is I
really feel that the spirit of this of
matching the basis to fit the computer
rather than the other way around it's
probably the way we need to go I have a
very speculative question based on
essentially the introductory part of
your talk so when you go from localized
things like these Gaussian things to
plane waves there's an intuition that
along the way there are other things
that might be looked at like for
instance wavelets do you have any sense
of whether those might be useful for
computations like the ones you're doing
here wavelet basis are a hot topic these
days there's there's a lot of work in
there and there's been a lot of great
success that's gone into it however one
of the things is that I don't see any
reason a priori why we would get the
dramatic reduction in terms of the
number of terms in the Hamiltonian so it
may require it's going to require some
more work and people are looking at
these things let's think Nathan one more
time
[Applause]